Selina what do you think should we do it
again
[Applause]
everybody Selena Gomez surprising a
crowd at Julia Michaels a Los Angeles
concert on Monday night always wanted to
be one of those so put your hand up if
you're scared but just know ya the bear
sang their song anxiety live together
for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
and I witnessed lzt that Selena was in
high spirits and super smiley throughout
the night and at the end of the
performance Selena and Julia exchanged a
quick kiss before Selena walked off the
stage
[Music]
[Applause]
and after the show Selena and Julia got
matching tattoos tattoo artist London
Rhys documented the moment my boy tattoo
girl Selena Julia we gave the mansion
Tati's now Selena and Julia have been
friends forever
julia has also written a ton of Selena's
hits with her including can't keep my
hands to myself
[Music]
oh and she told eg this last year she's
amazing and I think she wants to I think
she wants to do her own thing and have
her own words and her own expressions
and and I think that's amazing I want
her to flourish yeah she deserves it she
doesn't has everything I love that
friendship that you guys have it's
always fun to see the dancing videos in
the studio she's everything to me I
wouldn't I wouldn't be doing this
without her
[Music]